I paid $100 for this box and I have no
idea what's inside I am about to go
shopping on eBay right now to buy
mystery boxes what's in a mystery box
nobody knows except for the eBay seller
they just throw some stuff in a box put
it on eBay and apparently people buy
that sometimes now you might be asking
what kind of idiot would buy something
before knowing what it is
this idiot right here is gonna do it it
just says mystery box and the photo is a
picture of a question mark that looks
like it was drawn poorly in Microsoft
Paint I have to buy this it's $15 this
listing is also vaguely insulting it
says just buy it it's 15 bucks you cheap
ass I have low self-esteem so I'm gonna
buy it this $50 mystery box says totally
strange and also something totally
useful I don't know what that could be
what's both strange and useful and cost
$50 like a turtle I don't know I'm gonna
pull the trigger on this $100 mystery
box because I got it I got to see what
an expensive mystery looks like it could
literally be anything someone out there
could have farted in a box put it on
eBay for $100 and I'm gonna buy it I
can't believe I spent so much money on
mystery boxes
just got my first mystery box in the
mail very excited I want to know I open
it know and I open it and not tell you
what's in it no it's my mystery box this
box is pretty small and I thought I
don't even remember which one it is but
it's like this is the big one the
granddaddy the $100 mystery box it's
finally here this is my stack of mystery
boxes I've never been more excited to
open something in my entire life I'm
either gonna look like an idiot or this
stuff's gonna be really cool but I'm
probably gonna look like an idiot this
was the cheapest mystery box it was $15
it's very lightweight I don't have high
hopes for this like a crutch Oh Wallace
I'm trendy glasses the listing was very
aggressive so I'm a little scared oh I'm
sorry this could just be a box of hair
what if this is a treasure map what if
it is like poison I don't know let's
clean up are you scared to look okay
okay okay okay okay what is this
[Music]
is this like a broken iPhone this is
literally like a broken part of an
iPhone I've paid $15 for a small box of
garbage
okay so let's hope that the mystery
boxes get better when they increase in
price this box was 50 bucks maybe it's
like a Roomba cooking machine and only
cooks hot dogs now that I know it can
definitely be garbage I'm a little bit
worried to open this maybe like a
watermelon there's a lot of stuff in
here
and it kind of feels like very heavy
shoes
there's a little smiley face what is all
this stuff oh my god are these fireworks
I don't smell like smoke this just says
here is a bag of strange what have I
done
are these dead batteries what is it is
this a gumball is this a loose this is a
loose gumball is this just no this is a
bag of carving to catch flies there's a
loose gumball I can't moist towelette a
tiny Mickey statuette the thing that's
really got me upset is this floss pick
like if this is used that's horrifying
oh god there's actual stuff in here but
this person just threw in a bonus bag of
garbage with a little smiley face
there's a book called how to speak
southern spinach seeds watermelon seeds
whoever saw the Thor was a watermelon in
here
it's not wrong Sonic the Hedgehog game
vintage salt and pepper shakers this is
not total garbage kind of cool oh okay
$100 let's find out what $100 of mystery
looks like magic it I paid $100 for it
why 100 that you don't even know what it
is this is like scary Christmas probably
like a tacky lamp because I'll an attack
it's got to be like an insane amount of
genes what is this it smells weird this
is like some stuff okay
this doesn't look like trash which is
very exciting first thing we see is a oh
my goodness it's a biography of Ronald
Reagan Wow
there are pants in here there's a lot of
pants there's a straw purse this is kind
of cool this is definitely like ladies
stuff is there anything in this purse
there is oh my goodness huh okay there's
this belt
oh what the this looks like someone's
like wallet this is so weird so here's
this like I do not know what are these
perfumes these are no these are used
like little on-the-go toiletries breath
spray what does that mean I feel like
these are partially empty so it's not
like it's new whoo tweezers from a
stranger
got some shorts Oh Armani Exchange okay
we got a skirt all right a skirt god
there's like weird stuff coming out of
this box a bunch of cloth napkins Oh
my god I feel like instead of going to
Goodwill this person just put all the
stuff in a box and shipped it which is
probably more work than just dropping it
off at Goodwill then again they did get
$100 for worthless junk
oh that's musty as hell oh wait there's
one more thing it's maybe breakable
what is it it's like dust oh my god is
this like a piece ha ha it's a pipe so I
believe this is drug paraphernalia or
smoking marijuana so there's a bunch of
like lady clothes a Ronald Reagan book
and a pipe for marijuana these were the
most exciting boxes I've ever opened
even though they contained trash they
were very fun to open I don't think any
of the things that were said to me were
worth any money at all but it was
exciting it was exciting it did bring
some mystery into my very dull life if
you want like maybe 30 seconds of
excitement and then hours of
disappointment and wondering why you
wasted money get a mystery box from ebay
it makes me want to put my junk in a box
and try to sell it on eBay but I don't
know if there's as many dumb people out
there like me that will actually buy it
part of me wants to chew this gum ball I
know I shouldn't choose gumball but like
I do love
[Music]